the speculation is over joe biden has
named kamala harris as his pick for vice
president
both will appear together in delaware
tomorrow
biden tweeting i have the great honor to
announce that i've picked kamala harris
a fearless fighter for the little guy
and one of the country's finest public
servants
as my running mate back when kamala was
attorney general she worked closely with
beau
i watched as they took on the big banks
lifted up working people and protected
women and kids from abuse
i was proud then and i'm proud now to
have her as my partner in this campaign
and kamala just tweeting her first
response saying quote
joe biden can unify the american people
because he spent his life fighting for
us
and as president he'll build an america
that lives up to our ideals
i'm honored to join him as our party's
nominee for vice president
and do what it takes to make him our
commander-in-chief
so we will get to all of this news i
want to start donna brazile with you
uh one a historic day for kamala harris
and for
the nation the first black woman to be
uh
appointed to one of these positions
she'll now be on the ticket with joe
biden i know that you got the news a
little bit earlier today tell us about
your reaction well first of all i'm
excited she is a daughter of
immigrants she's hard working she's
tenacious but most important
uh uh kamala started like so many others
believing that she could do something to
help everyday ordinary people
when she graduated from howard
university which is located here in the
district of columbia
a historical black college and
university she decided to go back home
and worked in the da's office where she
handled a lot of the
sexual child sexual abuse cases i saw
her grow into the position of
being elected to the d.a office and of
course winning statewide
not only as the attorney general but
also
as a united states senator i think she's
going to help
the barton ticket i think she is going
to
help him govern if they are elected but
this is an exciting day
the fourth time we've seen a woman on a
major party
ticket so i'm very excited and i cannot
wait to
uh get to work because there's no time
to celebrate we got 84 days so i'm ready
to get to work
one of the things that happened during
the primary campaign during the debates
is
kamala harris did take a big swipe at
joe biden some said she gutted him
on the campaign trail you might remember
this exchange take a look
to hear you talk about the reputations
of two united states senators who built
their reputations
and career on the segregation of race
in this country you know there was a
little girl in california
who was part of the second class to
integrate her public schools
and she was bused to school every day
and that little girl was me it's a
mischaracterization my position across
the board i did not praise
racist i agree that everybody once they
in fact
my time's up i'm sorry
kids
so greg obviously there have been
moments in primaries where
future vice presidential nominees have
said even worse things
about whoever the actual nominee ends up
being but apparently joe biden was
able to forgive this but there was talk
that dr jill biden
biden's wife took this as a real swipe
against her husband and found it a
little bit more hard to forgive
uh kamala harris will obviously be asked
about this um whenever she does an
interview
yeah it's i think it's really pointless
to ask about what people do in a debate
uh if we can we remember in uh 2016
in uh leading up to that election trump
said a lot of stuff
and everybody says stuff and then when
it's all over
everybody's working for each other which
is kind of spooky in a way
but i agree with donna brazile she does
help the ticket because
she has a pulse and she immediately
improves the ticket because she can
complete a sentence
so already we've reached a new high i
did get some news from peter ducey
though that liz
warren is now self-identifying as kamala
harris
and gladly accepts the invitation to the
ticket
i don't know how they're going to deal
with it i find that very strange
but we can also pretty much agree that
joe wasn't involved
in this decision i don't believe he was
in the room
he might have been in a room but not the
room
maybe a room with a shawl and some hot
chocolate
but i do think that somebody else made
this choice and i and i will say this
again
i don't think the ticket is done yet
i know you that's been your position and
so you're sticking to it
katie one thing that was swirling around
this week is that susan rice who had
been the national security adviser for
uh barack obama was under consideration
and one thing i i thought about that is
that it would really tie
joe biden backwards right to the barack
obama administration which for many
democrats
you know they they loved but this ticket
is new and it is a signal
that they want to move forward i'll let
you give your reaction either to that or
your general impressions
of this pick yeah it would have been
very easy with susan rice on the ticket
to say this was obama's third term
that the left is not looking forward but
instead backwards
but i find it very interesting that she
is the pick and i'm very curious about
how the focus group sessions went
because
one of joe biden's largest biggest
vulnerabilities
during the primary and in the general
election is
his support for the 1994 crime bill and
while joe biden
passed it with support from the black
community at that time
the opinions about that bill have
changed this number of years later and
kamala harris was one of the people who
enforced
that legislation as the attorney general
of california
so it'll be interesting to see you
remember when she went on that radio
show and she
joked about how yes she'd smoked weed
and she got a lot of
backlash for putting people in jail for
doing exactly what she was joking about
so i'm curious about which constituency
she satisfies here she
california will go blue regardless of
who's on the ticket republican or
democrat so we'll see
how it's going to work out but it's a
nice play for the first african-american
female president should joe biden decide
to step aside at any point
jesse waters also we have to think about
this just practically in terms of
what does it get joe biden from this
ticket right it doesn't necessarily
expand the map
as uh katie was just pointing out
california has been voting democrat for
a long time
but across the board like does it help
anywhere else do you think
i don't know if it gets him that much at
all i mean she's kind of a phony
who never caught on i agree with greg
this is kind of like when you go out to
a restaurant with your grandfather and
you have to order for him
you take the menu and you're like you
know uh he'll have the
um the rib eye and you like it medium
right graham yeah she likes it medium
joe didn't make this pick this pick was
made for joe
and it just shows you the kind of bad
judgment and bad instincts
that the biden campaign has i wouldn't
trust kamala harris
i think she's very ambitious and we all
know joe's only running for one
term so you're basically ushering in
someone that's gonna
i don't think have the best um
intentions
she she was someone that couldn't even
manage her own campaign
i mean it was totally mismanaged it was
a
complete catastrophe i guess she was a
strong prosecutor and
she will prosecute the case against
president trump
she's very telegenic i get that the
media will say she's very hip
and obviously the media is going to say
she's going to beat pence
in the debate that's that's already been
preordained but
she doesn't really have core beliefs you
remember she was for medicare
for all until she found that it wasn't
really smart politics
then she tried to back out of it but the
more and more
the audience in the democrat field
watched her
the lower her numbers got and i just
spent dana a week
in a house with democrats and none of
them
was excited about kamala harris
did any of them have scissors to cut
your hair which
apparently has grown so long already in
the back
i got to go back when you turned your
head i couldn't believe it i got to go
back
you do all right i want to bring in
peter ducey he is in wilmington delaware
with an
update on this announcement peter we
talked about it at two o'clock
and here we are at five we got the news
here we are i hope you can take jasper
out now it seemed like uh
eric garcetti was telling you not to go
too far for a while
i remember being at a kamala harris
campaign event in nashua
new hampshire in may 2019 where
a reporter asked kamala harris if she
would ever
join the ticket join a joe biden ticket
he was leading in the polls at the time
and she said that
she thought joe biden would make a good
running mate for her
because he knows a lot about being the
vice president
obviously though to jesse's point about
her popularity with democrats
she did not catch on when it mattered
the most as a candidate herself and she
wound up dropping
out of the race the first week of
december 2019 never made it to 2020
despite a big push in iowa
to go all in there her
big position was to prosecute the case
against
donald trump but again it did not catch
on when she was
at the top of the ticket uh and despite
her
clash on stage at that first debate with
joe biden
as the summer that was in june of 2019
as the summer
wore on by september i remember asking
her a question and she said
leave joe alone so a lot changed from
her first initial decision to challenge
joe biden i'm sure there are going to be
a lot of questions
for her and the two of them announced
their first event
as a ticket it's going to be here in
wilmington tomorrow we're awaiting some
final details but sometime tomorrow
afternoon dana all right we'll see
maybe it'll land at two o'clock that'll
be good for the show thank you um
donna brazile i want to ask you about
this announcement that was made earlier
today that the biden campaigns
announced before we knew it was kamala
harris that
i think i believe it's eight staffers
have been assigned to
help her you know we're gonna get to
john roberts in just a little bit
because the trump campaign has already
responded
do you think that kamala harris is
prepared for what's about to hit her
with all of these attacks and questions
about prior
positions etc i mean
i want to respond to greg and jesse but
that would take up too much time so i'm
going to ignore them for a couple of
minutes but let me just say this
she's battle tested she knows what it
takes and because she was on that
campaign trail along with 23
other candidates let's be clear kamala
will be able to respond in real time to
not just the criticism some of it
you know such as ambition i'm glad
to see that she has ambition that is
what we want to see
and and our candidates they have an
ambition to do
more for the country and of course more
for those who are struggling during this
period of time
um the biden team has put together a
wonderful
group of people i know many of them to
help
kamala navigate this new terrain i think
they will do a fantastic job
and making sure that she's not only
ready for the one and only debate that
she will have but to get on the campaign
trail
to be out there virtually as she has
been over the last couple of months
and to continue uh to fight for those
big issues that joe biden has already
introduced that his campaign will focus
on
so this is a historic choice and i'm
excited about
uh the selection of kamala harris and i
hope that we get to know
more about her uh and not just those
little talking points that we sometimes
get on our computer
she's really a fantastic person all
right